the views and opinions expressed on this
program are those of the guests
appearing on the program
and do not necessarily reflect the views
and opinions of eight news now or next
our media group
on politics now elections education and
immigration we look through a host of
new bills introduced this week up in
carson city
the idea is to create a system of
integrity around
around esports generally that would
allow
for consumer and player confidence
the future of gaming state senator ben
kiefer details his plan to create the
country's first
esports regulatory body plus
i expect that we will move to a primary
system
i think the caucus has disenfranchised a
lot of voters
is change coming we speak with the new
chair of the nevada democratic party
about her vision for the future
from eight news now this is politics
now thank you very much for joining us
i'm john langler and we start in carson
city where the nevada legislative
session is chugging along
hundreds of new bills were introduced
this week monday was the original
deadline to introduce legislation but
now that's been suspended so let's talk
about some of the main measures many of
the new bills deal with
elections senate bill 292 was introduced
by democrat roberta lang
it would allow straight ticket voting
you can basically just check a box that
says republican or democrat
and all of the candidates would then get
your vote this also raises the
requirements for minor parties to
qualify for the ballot
county commissioners would not name
replacements
to seats in the legislature instead that
would go to the head
of that chamber whether it's the senate
or the assembly that's proposed in this
bill
republican state senator scott hammond
is trying to revive education savings
accounts esa's
senate bill 306 would allow families to
take public school money for their child
and then spend it
on a private school republicans approved
this measure in 2015
after a lengthy legal battle was
defeated when democrats took control
and they still oppose this now the bill
sets aside 60 million dollars to fund
esa's
a bill by democrat state senator dina
neal would cap
fees charged by online food delivery
platforms
senate bill 320 sets the maximum at 20
percent of an order on post mates
grubhub or other delivery sites or apps
it also adds in civil penalties if those
platforms offer to deliver food
without that restaurant's approval now
if you've been driving around you'll see
sort of beat up junk cars vintage cars
with those classic car plates you see
there
so this is a story the eye teams
reported on in the past
assembly bill 349 from democrat howard
watts would close the loophole that
allows that
right now any vehicle older than 20
years can get those
classic plates and it also exempts them
from smog checks
the bill would limit them to only being
able to drive 5 000 miles on the road in
a year
vintage vehicles would also need antique
car insurance
and would require antique car insurance
policy i beg your partner said that
twice
the bill also raises fees on smog
businesses again
if approved assembly bill 376 would keep
local police departments from
cooperating with federal immigration
officials
the measure was introduced by democrat
selena torres it bars law enforcement
from detaining someone at the request of
immigration officials
unless there's a warrant officers would
have to warn
people that answers to their questions
about their birthplace could be used
against them in the deportation heap
proceedings
former state senator ivana kinsella
tried to pass a similar bill in 2017.
a bill to change use of force rules for
police officers had its first hearing
this week
it's senate bill 212 sponsored by
democrat dallas harris
it would make it harder for police to
use deadly force have them stay a
certain distance away from suspects to
encourage de-escalation
and it also has limits for protests and
demonstrations police would have to give
an order to disperse and enough time for
those people to clear before they can
use
non-lethal force pepper balls for
example senator harris says
half of police shootings were deadly in
2019
and used a slide in the presentation
saying reno nevada for example
it's one of seven major cities where
police kill black men at a higher rate
than the u.s murder rate
republican senators believe this bill
presentation was unbalanced
it's pretty accusatory the presentation
was such that
it sounded like you know you know police
officers
i mean we're stopping short of a defund
police argument
but it sounded like you know these are
our bad guys
and for pete's sake these guys keep us
safe uh
and and they're the ones who run toward
the the danger instead of away from it
and i think they deserve a great deal of
respect for that
again if approved this measure would
also have the attorney general create a
use of force
database the bill has not yet had a vote
assembly speaker jason fryerson says he
is recovering from surgery now as he
battles prostate cancer
he returned to the legislature this week
friarson says he was diagnosed with the
cancer two years ago
and he has introduced a bill that would
make september prostate and ovarian
cancer awareness month
our vanessa mercury murphy spoke with
him about his treatment
men when it comes to these types of
procedures
uh get skittish and you know
you know you're a mother uh my wife has
two kids
um uh uh
you know i i'm frequently reminded of
how i don't know childbirth um and so
for something as simple as having your
prostate checked
um it's uh it's just a no-brainer
and it's such a non-aggressive typically
non-aggressive form of cancer
that it's so treatable if you're willing
to talk about it so
you know you know these are not the
kinds of things that people
uh you know are comfortable talking
about so let's normalize it let's make
it
uh comfortable to talk about not
embarrassing uh there are side effects
that
that um you know we need to talk about
so that we can you know weigh
those in our consideration um but i
think that the more
that that we talk about it the more
folks will be comfortable addressing it
and you know you'd be amazed at the
number of people even over the past week
that are comfortable talking to me about
you know their private issues and
challenges
speaker fryerson is now getting
cutting-edge cryotherapy treatment
in california the nevada democratic
party has new leadership
it's led by a slate of members from the
democratic socialists
of america judith whitmer is the new
state party chair
several members of the existing party
administration have now quit with the
turnover
it has sparked national headlines about
a potential socialist takeover of the
democratic party in nevada
i spoke with whitmer about her new
position and what's next
there's always been you know this a
little bit of a divide between
you know what direction each faction
wants to take the party but at the end
of the day we're all democrats
and we will unify and we will elect
democrats
that's what we're here for so we know
that
no progress is possible without electing
democrats
so progressives are very invested in
making sure that happens
and we're also invested in bringing
everyone together to make sure
that we are ready in 2022 uh because to
us it's
absolutely a necessity that we re-elect
governor sislek
and senator cortes masto and we have a
senate majority
we're not going to give that up we're
not gonna we're absolutely not going to
get that up
so we are here to do the work and i
think once everybody sees that we're
doing the work
to keep the democratic party not only
functioning but also expanding and
growing the democratic
party to include all different
ideologies and
also making sure that we're doing the
outreach and the community engagement
and bypass
bipod communities as well so you're not
concerned about again the quote
establishment democrat
kind of working around your own uh
your own team well i would highly
caution against that
because the state democratic party is
the only
effective structure for electing
democrats
and for doing that kind of work
especially working with the coordinated
campaign
we're very closely aligned with the dnc
right now
we are you know doing the work already
you know we're open for business and so
it's not to the benefit of our
democratic candidates
for there to be any kind of a divide or
for any kind of a work around
um because it it puts them at risk and
it puts our elections at risk
so it's very very important that we are
all working together we're all on the
same page
uh and i understand you know the little
bit of concern there always is when
there's transition or new leadership
but i'm here to elect democrats that's
my primary job
are you looking ahead already to having
a caucus
how that'll be given the changes for the
the next election
i expect that we will move to a primary
system
i think the caucuses disenfranchised a
lot of voters
although they were helpful in rural
areas to bring people together
um we were finding that you know a lot
of people found it difficult to
participate on caucus day
or weren't really comfortable
participating in that kind of a format
even with the early voting um you know
we saw that
that a lot of people early voted
and stood in line for hours to cast
their ballot you know
and and so that tells us that people
don't really like the caucus system um
we've got to move to a primary system
here in nevada
what's one big outside the box
thing that you want to do right away
for restructuring and get out the boat
um to make it
more manageable um and to make it more
personal
we're going to be doing a lot of um
zoom until we can do in-person events
at each level so that we're going to try
and get our candidates to engage with
people
earlier on not just at election time and
start holding like town halls
in every single district so that we're
engaging people now
not waiting until election time and that
people start to feel like they can give
that kind of input
hold q and a's we're also looking at new
texting technology
new voicemail technology
and we've put the entire interview with
judith whitmer at eight newsnow dot com
incidentally
she mentioned uh bipac in the interview
that is an acronym for black indigenous
and people of color that's a term being
increasingly used by progressive
democrats
coming up next on politics now could we
switch to open primaries
i think that's a system that recognizes
the fact that people are turning away
from the two major political parties
republican state senator ben kikifer
tells us about the realities of voters
behind
his election reform bill and will gun
control legislation pass we're going to
look at some laws being discussed after
two recent mass
shootings here in our country welcome
back to politics now
republican state senator ben kikifer has
been at the forefront of legislation to
try and help nevada adopt new technology
from blockchain to cryptocurrency and to
esports
i spoke with him about one of his
election reform bills and
his attempts to create the country's
first esports commission
why does esports need regulation in
nevada
i'm coming to this clearly and
very very focused as an economic
development bill
right so i think that esports as
the fastest growing segment of the
entertainment industry and sports
industry
is uniquely positioned to fit um
perfectly with las vegas
to create additional tourism
additional technology ecosystem and
additional remote work so those are sort
of three lanes of an economic
development platform that we've
we've agreed to uh at the highest levels
of the state from the governor on down
and esports fits all of those lanes
perfectly
so what this bill is modeled on is a
nevada athletic commission type of body
right
what are they going to regulate is it is
it the human component is its technical
component
what what can a commission actually do
when the actual event while maybe taking
place in las vegas
it's kind of everywhere there are both
online tournaments and in-person events
right and
you need to start by looking at those
in-person events um because something
that's held totally online we would
really have no jurisdiction over right
so
there has to be a nexus for us to have
some oversight for it so i think
you know the effort uh is to create a
partnership between
uh the state and this and the nevada
esports commission and industry to
both identify issues that would be more
appropriate for a commission to
to oversee um as well as
get those implemented so those could be
things like setting up standards
for competition and developing those so
that they're applied uniformly across
different different types of
competitions it could be enforcement of
things like team roster changes or
something of that effect so that
you know people people know what's uh
what's to be expected for
for those levels of competition you know
the bill specifically calls out
um drug testing potentially is something
that the commission could oversee
so the idea is to create a system of
integrity around
um around esports generally that would
allow
for consumer and player confidence
there's been a lot of discussion about
what happened with the last election the
primary and the general election
with the coronavirus and and how
the changes that were made to ensure
safety and so forth
um back then the secretary of state's
office suggested that this was going to
be the only time we did like the only
mail-in balloting that was sort of the
general
thought there um what do you think
or what are you proposing i think we
also need to look at the changing
reality of our electorate
and not just our election system i've
proposed in seneca 121
recognizing the fact that more than a
third or more than 30 percent
of the voters in the state of nevada
have decided not to be a member of the
republican or democratic parties
and the primaries most often decide
elections
i think we know that we've seen that um
and for the fact that
um our closed primary system doesn't
allow nonpartisans and minor party
members to participate
in the most important election of the
cycle they effectively get shut out of
represent
of choosing who represents them in their
government so i'm proposing an
open primary system uh it's a blanket
primary that allows
all voters to participate in primary
elections and it really changes how we
have to think about
our primaries we're no longer having a
primary that chooses a democratic
candidate and chooses a republican
candidate
we have all voters choose
to to choose who they want to go through
to the general election all candidates
go on one ballot
all voters get to vote the top two go
through to the general election and the
winner takes all
i think that's a system that recognizes
the fact that people are turning away
from the two major political parties
and it would give a stronger voice
to more people in this state to elect
their representatives in government
and hopefully bring us more together
well we have a lot more of that
interview with senator kikefer including
more on election reform suggestions and
how to try and fix
dieter you can see that interview at
eightnewsnow.com
so that open primary bill it's quite a
contrast to the straight party ticket
voting
uh that we talked about earlier in the
show that measure that's been proposed
we counted in fact at least 30 election
related bills so far
up in carson city others include putting
in ranked
choice voting moving to all mail and
expanding voting districts
another bill would amend the nevada
constitution to put some teeth
into the state's none of the above
option which is unique to nevada
if none of the above win a primary for
example then that party would have to
pick a candidate
not on the ballot and then if the
candidate won in the general election
a special election would be called we'll
keep an eye on all of that because
there's a lot of moving pieces
next on politics now working across the
aisle nevada democratic senator jackie
rosen
discusses her efforts to pair with a
republican senator
and try and get things done this is 8
news now
following another mass shooting
lawmakers debate whether more federal
gun laws are needed you're watching
politics now after two mass
shootings in the span of less than a
week gun control legislation is once
again coming up in congress
on monday 10 people were killed in
boulder colorado at a grocery store
last week eight people died in a string
of shootings in atlanta georgia
two bills have now passed the house in
washington d.c but now
they're in the bitterly divided senate
i've already committed to bringing
universal background checks legislation
to the floor of the senate when you
disarm
law-abiding citizens you make them more
likely to be victims
these shootings have brought the issues
of gun control to the forefront once
again in washington even before the
shootings happened in fact
democrats were considering federal gun
law changes and as you see our
washington correspondent alexander limon
is here to discuss
details of these proposals alexandra
what's included on capitol hill
the u.s house actually already passed
two different gun control measures one
calls for
near universal background checks with a
few exceptions that allows for transfers
between family members
what kind of opposition will democrats
see on capitol hill from republicans
what do lawmakers on the gop side have
to say about this
near total opposition from the
republican side and that's obviously
going to become
possibly probably an insurmountable
obstacle in the u.s senate because
obviously they need 60 votes to get any
of these measures through the senate and
democrats have nowhere near
that amount of votes or support for
these measures but despite that
democratic senate majority leader chuck
schumer has promised that he will be
calling for votes
on the senate floor on the background
check bills at a minimum
and he says that's because polls show
that 90 percent of americans
support these bills including a majority
of
republicans and a majority of gun owners
so
i think what's happening here is that
democrats are trying to exert some both
political and
public pressure on republicans to get
them officially on the record
on where they fall on these background
check bills and possibly even force them
into a situation where they're
involved in a talking filibuster on the
senate floor
over this issue alexander limon from
washington thank you very much
so congress is working on better
coordination now between state and
federal governments to try and stop
domestic terrorism
this week nevada attorney general a ron
ford testified before the house
subcommittee on intelligence and
counterterrorism
ford opened his statement reflecting on
our one october mass
shooting and the standoff at the bundy
ranch up in bunkerville
ford says we may need to change federal
laws to better prosecute domestic
tourists
there are no easy fixes in the fight
against domestic terrorism
with the rise of domestic violent
extremism there is no question that
something needs to change
so that we can ensure public safety
meant to say domestic terrorists of
course ford also says
we need to take a measured approach to
protect privacy free speech
and the right to bear arms two senators
say they're working together to buck the
polarizing trend in washington d.c
nevada democrat senator jackie rosen and
west virginia republican shelly moore
capito
on cbs this morning the pair said that
they were trying to find ways to work
together
we don't have to be disagreeable when we
disagree we can focus on the things we
agree on
that's why people send us here that's
what they expect from their leadership
you all make it sound so easy in terms
of
bipartisanship what are you doing that
some of your colleagues aren't i think
honestly if you're asking where i think
some of our other colleagues
unnamed could improve i think the way we
disagree
sometimes is very disrespectful so far
the pair have co-sponsored legislation
to improve
broadband internet access and expand
opportunities in science and technology
for young women
and what to watch looking forward here
on politics now we're waiting for the
next major deadline in the state
legislative
session up in carson city april 9th is
the date where bills have to make it out
of their first committee it's the first
key deadline and that's where a lot of
bills end up getting
killed at this point the legislature is
sticking to that deadline of april 9th
and has not moved it back we'll keep an
eye on that as things move forward
or don't move forward as it turns out in
carson city thank you very much for
watching us here on politics now this
week don't forget you can stay up to
date online with all the political news
eightnewsnow.com we'll see you right
back here on saturday thanks for
[Music]
watching
[Music]